وصلت المواصلات دي كانت صعبه بالنسبه لهم
بعد الكيماوي وبعد الاشعاع اللي بياخدوه
فحالاتهم بتبقى صعبه فالحمد لله رب
العالمين ان ربنا وفقنا ان احنا نقدر نوفر
الجزء دوت اللي هو التوصيل المجاني بس
طبعا لما باجي بيه هنا معهد الاورام لان
انا برضو مريت بالتجربه ديت بحس بشعور
الناس وبحس بكل مشاعر الالم
[موسيقى]
محمد فاروق ابراهيم صاحب مبادره تاكسي
الخير لتوصيل مرضى السرطان بالمجان
المبادره دي قامت في 2010 والحمد لله
اتفعلت في الشارع المصري ولقيت اقبل وسع
كتير في الشارع المصري منذ فتره مرض
الوالده اللي هي ما بين سنه ونصف سنتين في
ناس كان بيقع على عاتقها مواصله
بجانب المرض بتاعهم فلازما حد يكون معهم
سلس ورؤوف ورحيم بيهم فقلت ان انا افعل
المبادره دي ولقيتك واسعه من كل سواقين
التاكسي معانا حوالي 270 تاكسي في جروب
التجاره مع الله في الواتساب والحمد لله
رب العالمين دلوقتي بيتحركوا ما بين 57
ومعهد الاورام شايفين شغلهم كويس جدا
وبسبها الحمد لله رب العالمين وزير
المواصلات فعل مبادره سكك حديد مصر مجانا
لمرضى السرطان والله كنت بشوف ناس كان
بالنسبه لهم وسيله المواصلات دي كانت صعبه
بالنسبه لهم بعد الكيماوي وبعد الاشعاع
اللي بياخدوه فحالاتهم بتبقى صعبه فالحمد
لله رب العالمين
[موسيقى]
رحلتي مع المريض بيبتدي يقول لي على
مشاكله في العلاج في حاجه ناقصاه في
العلاج في حاجه ما بيلاقيهاش طبعا هم ما
بيكونش مريض كانسر بس طبعا المناعه بيكون
عنده قليله رحلتهم كلها معاناه التاكسي
اولا مش تمليكار فالحمد لله احنا بندفع
الايجار بتاعه والحمد لله مش متاثرين باي
حاجه الحمد لله رب العالمين نشوف شغلنا
عادي اخر النهار طبعا بدايه المبادره ما
كانش فيه بوست اللي هي ايام فتره الوالده
وكده بعد ما توفت قررت ان انا احط البوست
عشان خاطر المريض اللي هو قدام معهد
الاورام ما يبقاش فيه انكماش او يقلق اما
اقول له اتفضل اركب طبعا في ناس بتستغرب
ده مجانا فبتستغرب فقررت ان انا احط
البوست على ضهر العربيه وعلى البربريز
الامامي بتاع العربيه عشان برده الناس
تعرف ويوم عن يوم الحمد لله الناس
متفاعله جدا مع تاكسي الخير وتاكسي الخير
موجود قدام معهد الاورام طبعا جميع الناس
عارفاه وكل مريض بيعرفه للتاني بقول
لحضرتك مصريين او غير مصريين وفي 57 طبعا
المرافقين بيقولوا لبعض النهارده على
طريقه التواصل الاجتماعي كل الناس بتتواصل
معايا والحمد لله في ناس مرضى وغير مرضى
بيتصلوا بيا وبيدعوا لي والحمد لله رب
العالمين مش مقصرين معهم في حاجه الحمد
لله رب العالمين
بالنسبه للراكب العادي اللي بيركب معي
طبعا بعد ما بخلص مشواري مع مرض السرطان
في ناس بتعرض تبرعات فطبعا احنا بنرفض
الحته ديت وفي ناس بتحدف فلوس في العربيه
برضو انا ماشي برضو بوقفهم وبقول لهم يا
جماعه يا ريت الموضوع ده يوصل لمستحقين
والله دي الصدقه جاريه على روح الوالده
وربنا يتقبلها طبعا فهو ده اللي احنا
بنسال عليه مش في احتياج الحاجه زي كده
عاملين جروب التجاره مع الله اي حد قريب
من معهد الاورام او مستشفى 57
بيتحرك بيبقى جنب المستشفى بحيث ان هو
اقرب واحد يتحرك لمعهد الاوراق 57 والله
بنقول لسواقين التاكسي يا ريت نخلي بالنا
من المريض ونجمعها الاورام او الامراض
المتوطنه والكبد برضو في الاثر العلمي او
مريض الغسيل الكلوي اللي احنا نقف جنبه
ونراعي شعوره وهو واقف على الرصيف مستني
مصل ومش شرط التاكسي اي حد معاه ملاكي سهل
عليه ان هو يعمل كده دي ربنا يجعلها في
ميزان حسنات الناس ما فيش حاجه يعني بتروح
كده
[موسيقى]